[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en el mundo
una de cada 100 muertes por suicidio por
eso cada 10 de septiembre se conmemora
el día mundial de prevención de este mal
promovido por la organización mundial de
la salud y por la asociación
internacional para la prevención del
suicidio este año el lema es crear
esperanza a través de la acción y la
invitación es a vivir la vida vamos a
conversar precisamente el tema con luz
maría salazar ella es consultora
nacional en salud mental de la ope es ms
colombia luzmaría gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros en france 24 en el año 2019
el último en el que se registraron datos
más de 97 mil personas se quitaron la
vida en la región de las américas y se
estima que 20 veces este número puede
haber realizado intentos de suicidio
háblenos entonces por favor de las
causas médicas de este mal
esta conmemoración se hace básicamente
porque queremos que todo el mundo se
sensibilicen sobre el suicidio y su
prevención debemos aprender a hablar
abiertamente sobre el tema para que los
ciudadanos entendamos que cualquier
persona en algún momento de la vida en
un momento difícil puede considerar esta
opción como una respuesta para esas
circunstancias de manera específica el
suicidio no es un tema de personas sanas
o enfermas es el efecto de
circunstancias complejas que llevan a
que las personas puedan tomar pues una
decisión desesperada en un momento
determinado frente a una circunstancia
que en la mayoría de los casos tiene
solución y que son circunstancias
generalmente temporales no podemos
medicalizar una circunstancia que es el
efecto de
circunstancias
biopsicosociales
situaciones que están afectando todas
las esferas de la vida está en la
integralidad luther como son problemas
relacionados con su vida familiar sus
comunitaria y luz maría la quiero
interrumpir porque quiero preguntar
entonces si es un problema de salud
pública de salud pública lo que estamos
viendo con el suicidio en las personas
el suicidio si es un problema de salud
pública sabemos que los últimos reportes
de la oms indican que 700 3.000 personas
mueren por suicidio cada año lo que
equivale a una persona que muere por
causa de suicidio cada 40 segundos el
suicidio se puede producir en cualquier
edad a lo largo de la vida y es la
segunda causa de muerte entre los
jóvenes de 15 a 29 años en todo el mundo
el último informe de la ope s indica que
el número promedio de muertes por
suicidio por año en la región de las
américas es de 82 mil casos o una tasa
de más o menos 9 personas por cada
100.000 habitantes estas tasas de
suicidio
indican que el suicidio se da por en el
78 por ciento en hombres es decir por
cada hombre que se suicida uno por cada
mujer que se suicida hay tres hombres
que toman la misma decisión
cifras realmente lamentables pero además
hay otros factores de riesgo como la
pérdida laboral el trauma o el abuso
cuáles son esas situaciones que deben
llamar nuestra atención para pedir ayuda
bueno básicamente es importante que
todos tengamos en cuenta cuáles son esos
factores de riesgo que pueden llegar a
desencadenar que una persona haga un
intento de suicidio o comenta el
suicidio sabemos que los principales
factores de riesgo tienen que ver con
conflictos con la pareja en la mayoría
en un 39.9 por ciento de los casos
problemas económicos maltrato físico
psicológico o sexual violencias
asociadas a los entornos educativos
enfermedad y dolor crónico enfermedades
dolorosas o incapacitantes el acceso a
medios letales por supuesto la presencia
de trastornos mentales crónicos que no
han recibido suficiente apoyo o que no
tienen el tratamiento médico y/o
psicológico el abuso de sustancias
psicoactivas especialmente el abuso de
alcohol
y hay un factor de riesgo muy alto que
son los intentos de suicidio previos así
como el sufrimiento generado por
violencias durante la infancia serían
los factores de riesgo que generalmente
están asociados con intentos de suicidio
luz pues gracias por su tiempo hablar
este tema tan delicado y tan necesario
hablar de nuestra salud mental además
saliendo de esta pandemia que a thor nos
ha afectado alguna u otra manera gracias
por su tiempo por estar con nosotros en
cinco minutos ustedes continúen con
nosotros aquí en france 24
[Música]